greater energy independence will make
member states less vulnerable to the
kremlin's coercion
it will deprive the russian government
of massive resources that's used to help
bankroll its attack on the independence
of ukraine not to mention several other
countries in recent years president
putin's war of choice has highlighted
the critical importance of strong
transportation infrastructure
the region's roads rails and airfields
have been used by nato to move personnel
and equipment in order to reinforce the
alliance's eastern flank
they've been used to get life-saving
humanitarian and security assistance
into ukraine
and to get nearly 6 million civilians
out of ukraine most of whom have found
refuge and remarkable generosity in your
countries vladimir putin is not just
targeting ukraine in his appalling
hybrid war
he's trying to hold us all to ransom by
weaponizing hunger and russian energy
he's gambling that the free world will
tire in the face of his aggression
we are not tired and we can never tire
in defense of freedom and democracy
and we will show that by doing
everything possible to ensure that
ukraine prevails for too long countries
have used their heft to coerce and exert
control
that ranges from russia with oil and gas
to china with technology and strings
attached debt
it's imperative we strengthen our
economic security
by deepening our trade sharing our
expertise in science and stepping up to
provide honest and reliable investment